bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag depuis
le 18 janvier dernier la vaccination
s'organise sur saint quentin en yvelines
le vélodrome s'est transformé en
vaccinodromes pour les personnes
prioritaires
nous avons rencontré les personnels
soignants et les élus qui travaillent de
concert contre la pandémie
la vaccination s'effectue également dans
les cabinets des médecins généralistes
et dans les pharmacies
nous verrons comment ces professionnels
s'organisent et comment procéder pour
s'y faire vacciner place à la
vaccination
c'est parti
[Musique]
le vélodrome
lieu emblématique de saint quentin en
yvelines devenu symbole de la lutte
contre la pandémie de covin 19 depuis le
18 janvier c'est ici que s'organise la
vaccination pour les populations
prioritaires
[Musique]
pour des raisons de logistique un centre
unique a été retenu le site du vélodrome
s'est imposé de lui même
tout d'abord engagé dans deux salons du
site
l'action vaccinale a pris ses quartiers
début mars sur le plateau central avec
l'augmentation des doses de vaccins ce
plateau central nous permet en termes
d'accessibilité en terme de surface de
pouvoir installer donc ce dispositif
désormais composé de 24 box médecins de
24 box pour les infirmiers et les
infirmières
et puis les pauses pour le secrétariat à
peu près la moitié des personnes que
nous recevons donc s'inscrivent sur
d'octo libre sur les créneaux que nous
mettons en ligne régulièrement
et puis l'autre moitié un ou travaillons
avec les communes du territoire où nous
facilitons les transports donc avec des
groupes organisés la rs s'accorde à dire
que le vaccinodromes de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et
le plus important d'île de france
peut-être même au niveau national nous
travaillons donc accroître encore notre
capacité notamment avec les nocturnes et
puis notamment aussi avec une ouverture
7 jours 7 jours sur 7 pour cette
entreprise sanitaire d'envergure
l'agglomération à recruter des agents
d'accueil et administratifs étudiants
retraités et vacataires contractuels
tous sont venus apporter leur concours
le personnel médical du territoire s'est
aussi investi alain janicot ordonne le
pôle des 80 médecins qui interviennent
sur le vélodrome
ceux ci se sont mobilisés malgré les
nombreux rendez vous au sein de leur
cabinet ça veut compliqué parce
qu'effectivement une vacation c'est mon
départ à notre cabinet pour pour faire
pour accueillir donne aux patients et on
se posera la question de se trouver
l'équilibré entre le soin qui est
indispensable la poursuite du soir et la
vaccination qui elle aussi est
indispensable
[Musique]
le fait d'être nombreux permet de voir
des turn over pour ça des rotations qui
sont qui sont insuffisantes pour faire
face pour l'instant notre originalité
ici c'est d'avoir un petit pourcentage
des pressions qu'on peut inscrire à
travers nos patientes l on a tous les
médecins qui viennent intervenir ici on
lit cette passion qui peuvent appeler au
certaines personnes qui ont très bien
compris l'appeler pour qu'il soit
disponible au dernier moment et en fin
de journée quand on fait le calcul pour
justement ne pas perdre 2 2 dès
l'arrivée des candidats des médecins
vérifient leur température puis un court
bilan médical est effectuée dans un box
mais la dernière fois
comment ça s'est passé aj petite plaque
rouge qui m'a démangé c'est tout
cette fois là ça peut être paradis
abordables mais s'est rarement d'accord
donc a priori cela se passait je viens
participer aussi à l'effort national de
vaccination j'étais 30 ans médecin il en
cours mais et
je retrouve le contact avec plaisir ces
lieux qu'on soit plus nombreux
ça donne plus de temps avec eux les
patients qui ont besoin de comprendre
ensuite c'est l'injection infirmiers et
infirmières contrôler une dernière fois
l'état médical du patient
la dose administrée les nouveaux
vacciner à temps de 15 minutes en salles
d'attentes pour vérifier l'absence de
réaction allergique
c'est ma deuxième injection oui on sent
rien du tout bon pour les effets
secondaires la première fois je n'ai
rien ressenti une petite douleur au bras
c'est tout alors donc aujourd'hui
j'espère que ce sera la même chose
la première c'était très très bien passé
j'espère que la deuxième ce sera pour
elle il n'y a pas de raison avec moi
j'attendais avec impatience d'être
vacciné je me suis occupé de procurer un
rendez vous dès le premier jour où les
inscriptions étaient possibles en ligne
par dr il faut reconnaître que ça a été
plus compliqué car si compliqué
heureusement j'ai une belle fille qui
s'est débrouillé un jour alain
téléphoner téléphoner téléphoner et en
fin de compte elle a eu une place pour
moi aujourd'hui
chacune est rassuré rassurer puis
surtout une envie davantage sortir de
voir ma famille mes petits enfants je me
sens soulagée j'ai l'impression d'être
un peu plus libre la hausse des
contaminations dans certaines régions
notamment en ile-de-france a obligé le
gouvernement a réorienté les doses vers
les régions les plus impactés ce fut le
cas pour le week-end du 7 mars les
équipes du vélodrome ont dû s'organiser
en moins de 36 heures pour organiser une
opération exceptionnelle
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup de monde
c'est
c'était très tendu mais c'était ça cool
et c'est très bien parce que c'est très
bien organisé
ce qui a vraiment mieux beaucoup
beaucoup de moyens et ce depuis le début
de la crise sanitaire pour trouver et
distribué des masques pour organiser les
tests et aujourd'hui pour vacciner
malgré la pénurie des deux
[Musique]
depuis le début de la crise les 12
meilleurs saint quentinois se concertent
une fois par semaine en visioconférence
pour optimiser la réponse face à la
pandémie
[Musique]
la vaccination se déroule également dans
les cabinets des médecins généralistes
et dans les pharmacies
nous avons rencontré ces professionnels
qui viennent renforcer le dispositif
vaccinale depuis début mars les médecins
de ville ont rejoint l'action vaccinale
pour répondre à cette impériosité
sanitaire certains ont ouvert de
nouveaux créneaux dévolu à la
vaccination y compris le dimanche
le docteur erazo également présente au
vélodrome organise les vaccinations le
samedi matin dans son cabinet je voulais
juste avoir un jeune fan le vaccin est
ce qu'il y aura dans la réaction est ce
que j'aurai la température et tous les
combien tous les combien d'heures je
dois poindre de l'ipag on peut avoir de
la pièce action après de bassac été l'un
terne qui assiste le docteur erazo liste
les effets indésirables possibles
une douleur au niveau du point
d'injection un état grippal avec de la
fièvre des frissons des maux de tête des
courbatures ou de la fatigue et depuis
peu les éventuels cas de thrombose
inquiète
si vous avez une forte douleur à la
poitrine ou si vous avez une douleur au
relais nous rappeler soit vous appeler
le 15 renseignements pris sur l'état et
les antécédents médicaux du patient
celui-ci vacciner mon nom tout bon un
certificat de vaccination est remis aux
patients
le rendez vous est pris pour la seconde
injection dans douze semaines
moi j'ai décidé de vacciner le samedi
matin on ne fait que ça je ne fais que
ça quand jacques sin comme ça je peux
surveiller les gens qui sont dans la
salle d'attenté je peux répondre à leurs
questions
[Musique]
je ne suis pas déconcentré par d'autres
types de problèmes depuis peu le vaccin
astrazeneca inspire la méfiance des
patients donc c'est compliqué de leur
expliquer qu'en fait il ya quand même
des critères d'éligibilité pour aller au
vélodrome peuvent bénéficier d'une
fadeur du moderna que l'astra zeneca est
un excellent vaccin
enfin moi j'ai failli signer les membres
de ma famille avec l'astra zeneca donc
voir nos jeunes étudiants sont vaccinés
avec avec l'extra zeneca par contre
c'est pas que beaucoup de personnes
qu'on appelle qui seraient éligibles à
ce vaccin refusent de se faire vacciner
que ce vaccin donc pour nous c'est que
ça va être compliqué plus compliqué
aussi pour faire face au manque de doses
annoncée le nombre de doses a baissé
voir cette semaine on n'a pas eu du tout
la semaine prochaine au lieu des trois
doses promises en a qu'une dose une
situation identique dans les pharmacies
on a eu tout de suite des appels pour
des personnes qui te renseigner pour
savoir s'il fallait se faire se mettre
sur liste d'attenté
quand est-ce qu'ils pourraient vacciner
etc
[Musique]
on ne sait pas combien de façon on aura
effectivement on attend d'avoir les
flacons pour mettre en place des rendez
vous ici les vaccins sont administrés
après 18 heures d'autant qu'en plus du
comptoir
les pharmaciens effectue déjà jusqu'à 30
test de dépistage par jour
chaque étape en fait de la peau vie dont
la gérer du mieux qu'on pouvait après
ces démissions qu'on nous confie en plus
bas on les accepte
il n'y a pas de question à se poser si
ça permet de vacciner au plus de plus en
plus de personnes au plus vite et que
qu'on le fasse et qu'on sorte vite de
ceux de cette crise qu'on retrouve nos
libertés
[Musique]
si on résume à saint quentin
cette crise
bien sûr ça a commencé par un problème
d'information donc très vite entre élus
ont ses coordonnées pour et avec les
chaînes de télévision sim et de
dédramatiser décide donner les bonnes
informations et lutter plus précise les
plus scientifiques possibles
[Musique]
quand ça suivait avec les masques cette
crise des masses même chose on s'est
rendu compte qu'on pouvait pas
travailler tout seul afin d'avoir les
communes peut pas trahi tout seul dans
qu'elles sont devenues un trait sont
approchés de l'intercommunalité
collectivités territoriales département
région ile-de-france ont travaillé de
concert
l'agglomération a également aider les
professionnels à se munir de systèmes de
protection puis les tests de dépistage
ont démarré dans les gares les gymnases
au vélodrome aujourd'hui l'heure est à
la vaccination
si on atteint 80% d'un objectif qu'on se
fixe qu'on nous laisse expérimenté quand
même avec le passeport de vaccination
l'ouverture des théâtres des cinémas des
musées des restaurants et c'est pour ça
qu'on se bouge qu'on essaye de se bien
sûr de se mobiliser
c'est une très belle aventure assez de
voir tous ces gens qui viennent donner
de leur temps
il est presque une fierté nationale un
sentiment d'appartenance à la france dit
on est attaquée de l'extérieur par ce
virus je dirais presque un réflexe d'un
esprit de défense pour sauver aussi
leurs concitoyens je trouve ça assez
admirable
ça vous redonne confiance dans la france
où l'agglomération s'attèle déjà un
autre projet la communauté scientifique
de l'université paris saclay associé à
l'institut pasteur et à l'inserm espère
travailler demain sur la pérennisation
de l'immunité des populations face aux
convives 19
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez également
consulter des spécialistes à l'institut
de promotion de la santé à trappes
aucune pathologie ne doit être négligée
ni les gestes barrière à très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]